Okay,
so it's in the 19 twenties.
It's after the world.
After World War One rushes in pretty bad
shape.
The villages are full of brutalized men
who have posttraumatic stress disorder
and lots of people who are not doing
well at all and the bloody intellectuals
come into the town and they say,
you know,
those successful farmers up the street
that you've always been pretty jealous
about in your useless manner while
they're actually pigs and demons who are
stealing from you,
so why don't you come out,
we'll form a nice little mob and we'll
take everything they've got.
And that's exactly what happened.
And all those people were killed or
raped or set off to Siberia in the
middle of the bloody winter where there
wasn't even anything for them to to
anywhere for them to live or anything
for them to eat.
So they all died.
And then the consequence of that was a
few years later,
6 million people starved to death in the
Ukraine.
And Malcolm Muggeridge had been
reporting on that since the 19 thirties.
And so that was the.
That was the first wind really that the
west God of exactly what was happening
in the Soviet Union,
but even at that point,
that bloody left wing intellectuals in
North America,
we're so damn clueless and in Europe
that they never paid much attention to
it with,
with the exception of certain number of
people like George Orwell,
who wrote 1984 and animal farm,
which is of course a discussion.
The main pig in animal farm is stalad
and of course,
and it's a story,
an allegory about the Russian revolution
whose basic motif is we're all equal,
but of course some all animals are
equal,
but some are more equal than others and
that's the motif.
That's the Motif of animal farm.
So there had been warnings all the way
through,
right from the beginning of the Russian
revolution to the West about exactly
what was going on.
But because Communist and Marxist
ideology is very good at Adelaide and
the at the week binds of idiot
intellectuals,
there was a huge section of the
population who was fomenting,
I suppose,
against the standard.
What would you call it?
Political,
psychological and social order.
Who were absolutely committed to the
ethic that's encased in statements like
from each according to his ability to
each according to his need,
which sounds perfectly wonderful if you
think about it for about 15 seconds,
but if you think about it for six
months,
becomes unbelievably murderous and its
reach and,
and,
and the intent.
And so anyways,
the French for whatever reason,
seem to be particularly opaque to
reason.
I'll give you an example.
So,
um,
the doctrine of Pol Pot in Cambodia that
also killed about 6 million people hit.
So what they did in Cambodia,
once the revolution occurred was decided
that everyone in the city were parasites
on the countryside because the
countryside full of farmers was where
the primary production was taking place.
And they regarded the city dwellers as
parasites on that fundamental
production.
So they basically emptied out the cities
and set,
sent all the people in the cities out to
work in the country as forced labor.
And 6 million people died there.
And the chief architect of that bloody
project got his phd from the Sorbonne
and said exactly what he was going to do
when he went back to Cambodia,
was cheered along by the French
intellectuals who thought that that was
just a fine idea.
So that's all background for why I don't
think any of you guys really know much
about 20th century history.
So anyways,
what happened in the 19 seventies when
when Soulja Nansen published the Gulag
archipelago was the.
It was so brilliant,
the book and so overwhelming and it's
emotional and intellectual and
historical power that it became
impossible for anyone to continue to
claim that Marxism slash communism had
any intellectual or ethical integrity
whatsoever.
It was done,
it was done.
And that's part of the reason why he won
the Nobel Prize.
And part of the reason,
by the way,
why the Soviet Union collapsed because
once word got out about exactly what was
actually going on,
there was no way of making a coherent
argument in favor of say,
exporting the Worker's revolution around
the world.
It's like the consequence of that was
well documented by social units and
seeing the western intellectuals tried
to make excuses for what had happened in
the Soviet Union by blaming it on
Stalin's cult of personality,
perversion of the original accurate
Marxist doctrine,
so they basically said,
well,
Lenin had Lenin lived because he died
quite young and was replaced by Stella.
Had Lenin lived.
The promised Utopia would have been
delivered,
but solzhenitsyn being an absolute
genius,
documented the relationship number one
be between the axioms of Marxist and
communist thought and the laws that were
generated primarily by Lenin and the and
the construction of these camps and the
Dea Kula,
causation and all the mass murders.
He documented the causal relationship
between them and laid them clearly at
the feet,
not of Stalin but of Lenin.
And so that was also a major blow
because it.
It undermined the remaining argument of
the left wing radical left wing
apologists in,
in,
in the West for the,
for the viability of Marxist slash
communist doctrines.
And you still hear people today.
Many people,
when they're faced with the,
you know,
if they're,
if they're Marxist in their orientation
and they're faced with the data
pertaining to what happened in the
Soviet Union,
they'll say something like,
well,
that wasn't real Marxism,
but one of the things that you might
answer to that is,
well,
fine,
except that in every bloody country in
the world where that doctrine was
implemented,
new,
regardless of the wide cultural
differences between the cultures,
say the Soviet Union,
China,
Cambodia and so forth.
Exactly the same thing happened every
time.
And we still have a great example of
that today in the form of North Korea.
I don't know if you've ever looked at a
map of the world at night.
You know,
you can get a map of the entire globe at
night.
You look at South Korea,
it's lit up like jewels.
It's nothing but light like the east
coast of the United States and Canada
and North Korea is dark,
and the reason for that is that 50,
60 years of barbaric communist despotic
rule means a country that's completely
in an industrialized where every single
person is malnourished or starving to
death,
where everyone lives in terror all the
time and where there's nothing but the
continual production of labor in labor
camps just like in the Soviet Union in
Mao's,
China.
So if we were willing to pay attention,
we could still see examples of that
today.
And that's not an anomaly.
North Korea is exactly what you'd expect
given the doctrines upon which it's
founded.